well let's shoot let's buck in when the
[ __ ] in the world starts getting back
together let's let's make something
let's make a collab and make some sort
of video whether it be like a we were
talking about like a little mini
documentary or yeah let's uh link up
with me and Pablo and Luke will try to
collab on some sort of sort of cool [ __ ]
together if it's just some dumb graphics
or memes yeah dude like we can oh man we
could like document the next project
because I just I just now through our
quarantine I just finished up this new
project so yeah man let's document the
next one
you know everything dude I want to I
want to get some shots at the brewery
yeah oh yeah I did one I do want to ask
you all of your stuff you have you
released I mean I don't think you have
released like a full-length like single
project album have you yes oh okay so uh
juvenile how that was more like a
mixtape yeah collab with lex luger right
baby Earnhardt was a full-length album
that was nine tracks that had Toy Story
had Nicole Richie with little B yeah
ernhardt remix with Oh Erin mmm wait
when you came up with that project
though did you have like was it
preconceived to be like that like did
you have in mind exactly what you wanted
to do like had you or was it just kind
of like spur of the moment you just want
you know you had a bunch of ideas and
you just wanted to get them out and then
just package them up into one project
honestly okay so juvenile hell I feel
like that only showcased just a little
bit of what I could do cuz mm-hmm cuz
obviously [ __ ] evolves right I mean
obviously you have an idea then it
evolved into something or like like one
project could just be like a certain
part of your life like the way you're
feeling your the way you're feeling in
that year or whatever yeah juvenile hell
is very it goes back to like the old
Waka [ __ ] you know I'm saying
yes very influenced by all the dads yeah
I'm saying like that whole project was
produced by Lex you know so it was
cohesively all the same sound so I
didn't really showcase any other
attributes mm that I had as an artist
you know I'm saying and it didn't really
show through juvenile house so with big
baby ernhardt
mmm it was like alright this is a
[ __ ] open play feel like you know
Santa's
you know all types of different
producers you know I can work with
whatever and yeah maybe
ernhardt came from the Dale Earnhardt
you know yeah Dale Earnhardt single so
it was kind of like a prelude or a
sequel to that single that's why the the
remixes on there were little Aaron yeah
man so I I just felt like I had you know
just bring [ __ ] back to that and you
know saying give fans a full-length
project you know do you like doing
full-length projects versus just doing
like spur-of-the-moment singles it
depends it depends cuz like when I first
started it was just single single single
singing yes I'm single and then like
which has got to be fun to do it that
way yeah oh yeah oh yeah and then like
growing as an artist it kind of more
thought more work to do fooling yeah and
like cuz I was doing that for like two
and a half years straight just single
out this thing about this angle and I I
feel like I was doing that because I
didn't know how to make a project yeah I
didn't know how to make some like
cohesive [ __ ] all the way through I was
just so used to okay singing boom let's
get it done you know so that that was
just my anxiety as an artist you know
saying and that's the way I was doing it
now I'm juggling both of them and I'm
getting better at making full-length
projects and having it from the start to
finish like Pablo was just over at my
credit the other day and like I was like
yo I'm gonna play every single song
front the back in the order that I think
it should sound
who knows let me know what you think and
yeah man just has to bouncing ideas off
of each other and should mm-hmm
yeah so yeah I feel like I feel like the
the right balance of singles and
projects should be done like I really
like making projects now yeah just
because like I got a lot of [ __ ] that's
I wouldn't say it's not single material
mm-hmm but it's it's like for an example
there's this song on big baby ernhardt
and it's called [ __ ] in Sweden and
it's a love that I love that [ __ ]
so it's a it's a whole it's a loop it's
a whole loop yeah of a sample my homie
Katie cut their head sampled it and I
couldn't have released as a single you
know it fits in the project I got close
with it yeah right I got a lot of ideas
and [ __ ] better yeah and it's like I
want to put that type of [ __ ] out cuz
that's just some extra so do you think
you could evolve big baby scumbags
character and brand as you create new
albums like as you create new albums you
think big baby ernhardt could completely
turn into somebody else definitely
because I work with so many different
producers like I got a lot of homies
that are at Mad Decent low-key I've come
with a lot of people from that pizza
slime not pizza slice a Ricky remedy are
you a lion Diplo of course Valentino
Cohen
yeah not those guys over there they got
some fire and Ivan you know Ivan posted
no snippets yeah I'm very like me I'm
very like you get it when you get it so
yeah man it can easily evolve into
something notes man I feel like I'm that
I always say this I feel like that one
Pokemon the the purple one that like
getting [ __ ] transform into ditto you
[ __ ] like transforms into whatever
dude like Toy Story bro like I say like
that
like when I made Toy Story it was like
me mocking a country song yeah like if I
made a country song this is what it was
sounding like you know saying it was
more like that so now I'm taking this
[ __ ] seriously like okay let me try to
make different genres of songs like you
know saying sometimes you got to chase
those thoughts when you have them as a
creative otherwise you just keep telling
yourself no and if you keep telling
yourself no over and over again then
you're never gonna get anything new out
mm yeah because the rapid the rappin
[ __ ] like you gotta have to like you got
a new other [ __ ] and then come back to
the rapid stuff because man like I've
been stuck in writer's block so many
times like yeah from rapping yeah I mean
like I try something else and it's just
like it clicks man it's like yeah so I
think I think what rapping it is a lot
about trying too hard like like if
you're trying too hard with the rapping
[ __ ] that it's not gonna come out you
know mm-hmm because wait what do you
mean wait when you say trying too hard
what do you mean just what rhymes look
like what word rhymes with this you know
you know like you know [ __ ] like that
cuz with with pop music of what country
music or whatever it's not really about
what word rhymes with what you know I'm
saying those genres it's more about just
the vibe of that [ __ ] like rap is the
only genre where people are worried
about they should actually rhyming you
know I'm saying that's what I mean by
just trying too hard with the with the
rat you know when I focused on do
another [ __ ] it was like oh man like I
don't got to worry about if I can be
Ryan Ronnie Wood it just comes to you
yeah yeah yeah you know I'm so it's not
more it's more so about the [ __ ] rhyming
but [ __ ] just making sense and you can
make any word rhyme with any word I mean
I'm the new gonna album though baby
rhymes they
Buick with he says burek did something
definitely always does that yeah is that
you can bend words to fit what you want
and you can bend them to fit whatever
verse or rhyming scheme you want you do
that always the work yeah but it's like
what advertising does when it makes up
words for a new like like family plan
for like a phone thing it's like you can
make up anything words didn't exist at
one point so you had to make it
eventually so why not keep making up
words who's to say that you can't just
invite your language is you gotta
thought exactly but you remember it and
it's so stupid it sticks with you yeah
that's the most important thing it do
remember it and whenever I see a Buick
now all I think of this little baby
saying Buick hey yo
t-pain had the most memorable when I was
canson man with language is fluid
exactly roses Canson dude and he bro
like he was making hats whisk and like
big-time
t-pain top hats with the whisk and it
was like dad's regular hat oh there's a
lot of words that I didn't tweet the
[ __ ] out of just the like rhyme with it
or like I'll say some type of funny way
like yeah okay any come to mind oh you
know and no honestly but on black Joe
Dirt there's this lyric specifically and
I say flex so hard I ain't even got a
rhyme and it was literally because I
like stuff in my Friday's I don't know
what lives comes before that but I was
like dude like look it it's like so hard
on you I don't even get around yeah but
it was like a self-awareness of it not
rhyming which is what makes it good
right yeah what makes it land
that's one of the best lines in it [ __ ]
hits hard [ __ ] yeah well thanks for
doing this bro appreciate it I really
appreciate that was great meeting you
man how ya doing
thank you man thank you appreciate it I
love this setup
[Laughter]